Even though we center our discussion of
accessibility on users with impairments,
we can all relate to the experience
of using it to interface,
which is not accessible to us.
Have you ever tried to use a desktop
optimized site on a mobile device, or
seen this content is not
available in your country when you
are trying to watch a video online?
So in a broad sense you've
almost certainly experienced
being unable to access something.
As we mentioned, this cause is
largely concerned with accessibility
in the narrowest sense of ensuring users
with disabilities can access content.
However, addressing accessibility
issues in the narrow sense
very often improves the user
experience for everyone.
To see where that's true,
let's look at an example with
some accessibility issues.
This form have several.
The user name text and some of the text
in the price details is low contrast.
So that's hard for
low vision users to read.
Having the form labels on the left and
the form fields on the right,
makes it hard for most people to
associate them and almost impossible for
someone who needs to
zoom in to use the page.
And this label isn't correctly
associated with the check box.
So I have to tap or
click this tiny square, rather than
being able to click the label.
Plus a screen reader user would have
difficulty figuring out the association.
So now let's wave our accessibility
wand and see with those issues fixed.
We've made that low contrast text DACA.
We've modified the design so
the labels are right next
to things they're labeling.
And we fixed that label to be
associated with the check box.
So now I can check and uncheck it
by clicking anywhere on the label.
I'm much more comfortable actually
using the accessible version.
Sure, I could probably get
by with the old version.
But it would cause some extra stress and
possibly cause me to make mistakes
if I was in a hurry or distracted.
True story, I once accidentally had
something shipped to me in San Francisco
instead of my parents in Australia,
because of a form that looked a lot
like the previous one we just saw.
So while we want to address
accessibility first and
foremost to avoid excluding
people from accessing things,
it certainly isn't a zero sum game.
We're more likely to
make things better for
everyone by addressing accessibility.